I have a lot of memories from from the
comic-con so even though I'm quite new
to it you know I I'm just seeing stuff
work it my car has been going out since
2008 I'm going well no wonder that car
is making a great living it's been kind
of a well-kept secret you know it's
amazing everybody in line comes up now
all over the world consistently I do it
actually in my show I say becomes a
thing where they come up and they say
let me tell you about my night rider's
story I said what do you mean and they
all have a story of who they watched
Knight Rider with and and who and how it
made a difference in their life of how
it impacted them and this trip was it
was an amazing story guy came all the
way from France to meet me and he said
his grandfather and him watched
Knight Rider that's nice he said no but
my grandfather was in the hospital and
he was dying and he took out his IV he
went down to the to the toy store and
bought me a Knight Rider car gave me the
Knight Rider car went into his bedroom
and died and he said it changed my life
and he said you made a difference in my
life and the theme of Knight Rider was
one man can make a difference and so I
always find a story like that to talk
about you know it's something that if I
have to give a speech what do I talk
about we you can make a difference so
the stuff that makes a difference in my
life are the moments like that the
Berlin walls awesome the most amazing
thing has ever happened to me was the
birth of my second daughter because I
was there I missed the first one
going on stage on Broadway you know and
and the little things when when there's
a small audience and you know you really
don't want to go out there but they're
just as important so I would always
think that my mother would say you know
those people are just as important as
10,000 you know so I look for the small
things and I look for the people that
that who come to these conventions
because you know that it's one of the
guys said to me the geeks shall inherit
the earth and he was in a wheelchair and
he is was tough because a muscular
dystrophy kid you know kind of all
messed up and I learned so much from him
because he was you know he was taught a
sense of humor in the end and the geeks
are about people that want to be
themselves and want to live their life
and don't really care because everybody
else is going to make fun of them but
they're so cool that they they see
beyond that and it then is a big lesson
to be learned in life and that's what I
think these are the conventions are
about it's about come out be yourself
have a good time and get on with it you
know it's our life to live I think
that's why people use well still now
because you're yourself and you come out
and you have a good time as well I know
that you're still doing so much stuff
you mentioned the shows there you've got
a comic book coming up as well tell us a
little bit about that well I had a Welsh
geek call me said I am I'm a geek and I
know you're dating a girl from Wales as
a I am he's the were living wills and
Anthony Hopkins home town and I have an
idea for the hopper so I love the Hoff
and I wanted to do something unique lod
and based on David Hasselhoff's
character and spongebob and and that
didn't pan out
know how to do it so he sent me a sketch
and I fell in love with it and he came
today and we came up with this the
sketch and the poster and already were
it's like in the fast track and people
are all responding to it and it's really
fun because we're able to do make
positive television and you know a
positive character that's fun and
entertaining and and I think there's
three things that are key to it it's a
heart humor in action and we're working
on that and it's all organic it's a lot
of fun do you think we'll ever see a
baby watch movie would you like to get
back there on the big screen with Mitch
you know I'm not really sure what's
going on with it you know I hear it's
gonna be a spoof and really funny and
then I hear that's not the same thing
with Knight Rider it's the people that
do the films are there they're kind of
really close connected in their own
little world and unfortunately they can
because they don't have a relationship
with their fans or they see how many
people have gotten I wrote of cars or
they see how night weather change their
life or they see how people really like
Baywatch they'll tend to go for just the
title like Knight Rider or Baywatch and
then make a spoof of it because they
don't understand the reverence to so
many people and I do because I've been
around the world because I live it every
day you know and every day is Wednesday
night we're coming back when's Baywatch
so I know that that it'll just take its
course in the meantime we just got you
know just keep moving forward finally
got a message for your fans out there
see it believe it and you'll live it you
got to see it first
and you got to believe in yourself
because the only persons are gonna do it
is you you're responsible for your own
life and if you change your life you can
change somebody else's so it carry
yourself first